now qatar is pledging 500 million
dollars for the reconstruction of gaza
following a ceasefire
that ended the worst fighting in years
between israel
and armed palestinian groups the gulf
state has contributed hundreds of
millions of dollars in humanitarian
and development aid to support previous
ceasefires well joining me now
is lulu al qatar the deputy foreign
minister
of qatar good afternoon good to have you
on sky news
there's a lot of reconstruction to be
done in gaza isn't there
how can you be confident that that money
will go
towards the reconstruction the
rebuilding and supporting of the
civilian population there
good afternoon samantha and thank you
for having me
indeed what happened in gaza was
catastrophic
and let's go back to the root causes of
this it's not
israel vis-a-vis military groups it
actually started all with the ethnic
cleansing that was happening in
neighborhood and talking about two sides
to this
aggression is a misrepresentation of
the situation we're talking about a
nuclear state that has one of the
strongest armies
globally and a stateless people now to
the
reconstruction efforts yes we have
commissioned half a billion u.s dollars
and most of that will be going for
rebuilding houses
within the coming five to six months we
are confident that we can
rebuild around 45 housing
units this in addition this is in
addition to
rebuilding some of the other facilities
for example the
qatari red crescent was demolished
in this war or in this attack on on gaza
so
some of that will go to this there was
of course the demolishing of al-jalab
building which hosted the associated
press journalists as well as al-jazeera
journalists so there is a lot to be done
in addition to
the hamad rehabilitation hospital which
was partially
damaged in this attack okay you said
most of it
there is is other portion of the money
earmarked for
other things
well in the past what happened was that
50
of the aid was going to the energy
sector
as you know the palestinians 2 million
palestinians in gaza
we're living with two hours of
electricity per day
until qatar intervened to increase this
to 16 hours per day
so some of that amount might go to the
electricity
sector as well and in the past 50 the
other 50 percent of the
previous aid used to go to the poorest
families
in gaza uh a hundred us dollars
per family this is barely the minimum
that any family can live with to provide
their
food and medication and i should
highlight here that our aid in general
qatar
does not only go to gaza it goes also to
west bank
for example the largest housing project
in west bank that is
project was built by qatar and the first
christmas tree that was
lit in 2018 was actually in that
project minister the reason i ask you is
because i've done many interviews
on this in the last few weeks and many
representatives from israel
say that a lot of the aid money has gone
for hamas to build up
its armaments is this aid money from
qatar
does that have israeli government
approval and
it's not in violation of sanctions
against
hamas
this claim is absolutely inaccurate
whoever has been
talking to you samantha was not saying
the truth
yes we do exercise very very strict
measures on our aid in general
and this has been done through the un
and obviously with the approval of
israel because to gaza you have
two passages it's either through egypt
and it wasn't going through egypt
so it has to be going through other
means and that is in this case
with the approval of the israelis so no
the quest
the answer is everything has been going
either to the electricity sector
or to humanitarian purposes uh most of
the commentators
from israel who are saying this they're
saying this for domestic reasons and
political reasons
for election purposes basically your
country is in a fairly unique position
of being able to
uh be able to help mediate um between
israel and hamas
um there's a comp there's a ceasefire at
the moment how confident
are you that that ceasefire will hold
well we have to remain optimistic this
was brokered through efforts
from the side of qatar egypt jordan in
coordination with the united states
yet what we're concerned about is
addressing the root causes of this
as you know this problem all started in
jerusalem with sheikh
neighborhood and unfortunately the
same measures taken against the
palestinians there are still remain in
place so we need to address this as well
and let me remind everyone that the
problem is not
israel hamas it's basically the struggle
of the palestinian people for the past
73
years we're talking about stateless
people
alone there are two million people who
are living in an
open air prison but we're also talking
about
many other millions who are refugees and
we're talking about
oslo that was never fulfilled not
because of the palestinians let's
remember that the two leaders who signed
oslo were finished
not by by the palestinians one of them
was assassinated
by an israeli fanatic the other one died
under siege
after three years of siege that was
yazid arafat so
once again we need to address this issue
holistically
for this minister do you think that
western nations working relentlessly
with egyptians with the america
i'm i'm sorry there's a time lag so that
we keep talking over each other
do you think that it is now the time
where western nations
need to deal with hamas
well i think it's about time for the
western nations to stop the
unconditional support both moral
and financial and in fact political to
israel
it is unconditional support the issue
once again it's not about hamas
this reductionist approach of reducing
the struggle of the palestinian people
since 1948
to only hamas is very problematic hamas
was only
founded in 1984 there were decades of
suffering before hamas
ever existed so yes it's about time for
the western nations
to start approaching this holistically
and
stop the struggling of the palestinian
people
and find a just and viable solution for
all nations basically calls from
all over the world for an investigation
into war crimes on both sides
the united states says any war crimes
investigation
will imperil the ceasefire what do you
think
i don't think this is accurate samantha
what the human rights commissioner
said was that the aggression from the
side of israel could amount to war
crimes
she didn't say the same about the
attacks from the
side of the of gaza basically so
once again we're not talking about two
sides we're talking about a nuclear
state with one of the strongest armies
globally and stateless
people who have been suffering for
decades samantha
those kids were kid killed basically
from uh the side of the palestinians
those are not hamas and not only by the
way the palestinians
do you remember rachel cory the american
activist
who was killed by the israelis in 2003
they are killing journalists they are
killing activists
not to say the truth so once again
it's not a two-sided aggression it's
basically
an occupation and israel is the last
colonial power that we know of in our
time and age
and minister with current leadership on
both sides
how do we find a two-state solution
that is indeed the question i think the
answer starts with
fulfilling all the obligations we have
oslo agreement
we have the arab peace initiative that
was put forward in 2002
and we have the u.n security resolutions
so i think fulfilling those obligations
will lead us to somewhere otherwise it
will be very very difficult
to maintain the current situation
and of course we as the state of qatar
remain open
to play any role to facilitate a just
solution
all right so really good to talk to you
this afternoon lulu
al qatar thank you for your time on sky
news